in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
and I was dr. smolka his head of the
psychotherapy and psychosomatics
medicine department of the Vic
McClintock at the Red Cross clinics here
in Berlin thanks for inviting me into
your pleasure we're talking about
burnout so the first question is is
Bernard a fashion disease I think
everybody has it Bernard is a fashion
disease sort of the past centuries there
has been always a change in technologies
and therefore there was always problems
of exhaustion so this is not the new
part of it the new part is that in our
society now which is defined by
globalization and new technologies for
example social media smartphones
personal computers there is a change in
acceleration when I had a busy day if
you tie it in the evening so but this is
not burnout is it yeah well this is
supposed to be working overload this is
quite normal for most of the employees
but if you have a burn out the severity
is much more a problem for the
individual so is it like a depression
mm-hmm there is a huge overlap of
sentence for example depressive
disorders anxiety or post-traumatic
stress disorders but Bernard is not a
disease or a desert disorder is a risk
factor and so it is a syndrome with a
huge overlap to all these mental
disorders but as a doctor you try to
treat MV the pre cursing disease the
burnout you don't wait for the
depression to develop well it depends in
Germany for example bernad is not a
diagnosis which is treatable in a
hospital you can go to your doctor and
stay there for treatment but if you go
into the hospital therefore the second
error disease is depression or anxiety
and what does the doctor do is there any
specific test to diagnose a bruising
well you have to watch very carefully
because bernad could be caused by
somatic disorders as well diseases for
example kidney failure systemic
inflammation or other diseases but if
it's a mental disorders disorder then
you should go to a psychiatrist or
psychotherapist and your general
practitioner might be able to suggest
this because mocha do you use meditation
techniques in the therapy of Bernard of
course because meditation is a very good
technique to reduce the stress level
there are asian techniques or more
Western techniques but overall it's a
very good therapy method to do that so
it is difficult to explain this to your
patients I mean we're in Western Europe
meditation is not not the main thing our
patients do yeah well it's such a
lifestyle method everybody knows about
it so ya don't have to have problems to
explain it it does it depend of the age
of the patient you the older the patient
is the more difficult it is to get them
into meditation could be sometimes
sometimes all the patients do have some
startup problems but then if they try
they are very likely to do so but this
is easily to be seen this is not a
meditation room this is more like an art
studio or you might call this so this is
painting therapy oh yeah it's called art
therapy exactly I could explain if you
would like to if you are burn or patient
you would draw in the beginning like
this because you have a loss of empathy
to your own emotions and therefore in
the middle of the therapy you will gain
access to the nucleus of your emotions
and the positive emotions and then for
example using mindfulness techniques
like dripping you could show your body a
very slow and very mindfulness way but
how does it actually work so you sit
together with the patient see in this
room and you say please draw a painting
and think
burn out while doing this yeah well in
the beginning it might be quite hard to
do so so you have explanation or you
have a style which would you suggest as
a therapist and later on in the therapy
you might be doing this by so-called
freestyle rather than one point but but
how does it actually work in the brain
for instance the our therapy is
occupation but no therapy which allows
the patient to find their inner emotions
and therefore they are able to express
it and in the end of the group therapy
for example the patient's talk about it
they get explanation they do explanation
and therefore this interaction helps
them to gain access to their for example
emotions the different kinds of
therapies next to our therapy next
meditation what kind of therapies do you
use as well yeah in the clinic we watch
have a multi-modal approach for the
secondary disorders for example
depressive disorders and therefore
psychotherapy as form in individual and
group therapy would be the first choice
and second choice there will be for
example sports therapy or fitness or art
therapy or other additional therapies
and in what do patients have to expect
for how long do you do they need to go
into therapy it depends a little bit on
the severity of the illness for example
you have shorter courses like four weeks
if you have a very severe secondary
disorder then you might be six to eight
weeks treatment to gain then your health
back and after that they go back into
the families back to the workplace and
they're all healed well-heeled is in
psychotherapy puted terms not the world
we would like to use we would say they
are able to reintegrate in the
Emily on the working place and needs
more time sometimes as an outpatient
therapy to gain full recovery and in
does it often happens that that patients
for baking to burn out after use for
instance well it depends on the
circumstances at work for example as
Bernard as a work related problem if you
can't change anything at your workspace
then you might are more likely to
relapse and that might be a problem of
course so it's really hard piece of work
you have to go through it yourself from
burnout that's right thanks dr. smoke of
inviting me today here we're not gonna
thank you
you